camps in eastern Sudan are the result of
the conflicts in neighboring Ethiopia's
Northern tigray Region more than 60 000
refugees have crossed the border since
the war between Ethiopia's federal
government and the rebel tigray people's
Liberation Front or tplf started in late
2020 letter Hanan sagai her mother and
two children were among the first to
escape the conflict two years ago but
with a deal signed in November she hopes
things back home will improve so that
she and her family can return
[Music]
my husband crossed the border with us to
Sudan and then he returned back to
Humera in Tigre he said he preferred
being there even if it meant his death
he's been there since I was born in
Humira in Tigre and I was raised there I
love my country and I want to go back
and live there with my children
the deal fined between the tplf and the
Ethiopian government calls for a
ceasefire and the disarmament of the
tplf federal forces will control the
Region's airport and other major
facilities the agreement also paves the
way for Aid to reach tigray where two
years of blockade has created a
humanitarian crisis while there may now
be peace in tigray at least on paper
refugees here say returning to their
homes is not easy many lost all they had
when they fled to Sudan others say the
situation in tigray after the deal was
signed has not been encouraging
also fled to Sudan at the start of the
conflict he set up a shop here in
umrakuba Camp he and rights groups
accuse Eritrean forces that fought
alongside the Ethiopian government of
committing atrocities the deal does not
mention them but highlight says certain
conditions must be in place for him and
his family to return home
is
should leave tigray for there to be real
peace but as long as they are there
there will be no peace how can they stay
it's not their country they're killing
people they've stolen properties they've
raped women as long as they're there we
cannot go back and there won't be peace
the war has left himalayans in desperate
need of humanitarian assistance and
thousands facing famine since the deal
was signed some Aid has started
trickling in but many are still in need
refugees like gabrizgar say going back
won't be easy
if we go back to Tigre what will we eat
what will we drink what will we wear
everything has been destroyed farmlands
have been burnt even those inside have
no food if International Aid can come in
then maybe we can go back home when
there is telecommunication functioning
Banks we need all of that
the word Integra has left an impact
Beyond just the region those inside
Ethiopia hope that the coming months
bring stability but those in refugee
camps outside the country say they'll
wait to see if the deal holds and things
improve before they can return home
people Morgan Al Jazeera gadariv Eastern
Sudan